welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and even though
this episode mostly consisted of a bunch
of grown-inducing wordplay for seven TV
critics that won't even enjoy it I'm so
excited that season six is back today
I'm going green by frame through season
six episode seven to cover all the
details you might have missed previously
on Rick and Morty let's start with the
episode title full meta Jack Rick is a
play on Stanley Kubrick's 1987 Viet War
drama Full Metal Jacket like the title
implies this episode goes full meta as
it deconstructs the writing pitfalls of
overusing self-aware humor the app opens
up with a recap of what we learned over
the course of the first half of the
season the first two bullet points are
true base Beth went downtown on Beth in
episode 3 and Rick managed to fix his
portal gun in episode 6 but Rick
realizes that something is weird when he
starts seeing bits and pieces of season
six's opening credits now seasons the
past have opening credits that include a
mixture of moments from That season and
other scenes that are just for the
credits so fans have been wondering if
we were actually going to see Sherlock
Rick and Watson Morty meeting Jack the
Ripper and the other credit adventures
all season it turns out that those
scenes really do solely exist in the
credits I'm kind of mad though about
missing out on butter Morty especially
because Rick says that this is the best
episode as they fly by with all the
metal layers of this episode though I
think that this joke is a nod to the
fact that Rick being turned into a
pickle is one of the series highest
rated apps Rick figures out that
something is really wrong when the
family finds themselves at Summer's 18th
birthday party where she announces her
pregnancy Jerry remarks that she's just
like her mom referencing Beth's teen
pregnancy with Summer after that Morty
dances in a meatball rainstorm a
reference to Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs next they flash to a church
where Jerry's funeral is being held in
the aftermath of a tragic beasting
accident you can even see the little
stick marks on his face in the coffin
this might be a my girl reference I
don't know it's a very sad movie if you
haven't seen it check it out you'll cry
Macaulay Culkin dies also note that
Beth's face is expressionless perhaps
her muted response to Jerry's death is
why she gets sentenced to death later on
in the recap spiral during her execution
the guard places a sponge on the top of
her shaved head fun fact in the process
of electrical execution a sponge is
dipped in salt water and placed Atop The
Condemned individual's pre-shaved head
this is to provide a better conductor or
point of contact for the zap zap that
causes you to take an eternal nap nap we
can also see summer holding baby Jerry
Jr at the execution to snap them out of
this spiral Rick tells Morty to propose
to him and the two are instantly
transported to a beautiful Seaside Cliff
wedding in the front row on the opposite
side of Summer and Beth you can see
Jerry's parents Leonard and Joyce and
their lover Jacob on their honeymoon in
a chamber that weakens the spiral Rick
and Morty chant next time on Rick and
Morty to neutralize the previously on
toxins from a pesky personified
storytelling device named previously on
after landing back home post Journey
Through the opening credits Leon Riggles
through a hole in the fourth wall back
to the metal layer Rick makes a
distinction that this isn't the same
thing as portal travel The Meta layer
isn't part of this Dimension or even an
alternate one it's an extra dimensional
plane past the fourth wall that
separates fictional characters from
their viewers Rick has Morty done a pair
of fourth wall glasses allowing them to
see story devices all around them
basically these shades are like if the
glasses from they live were hooked up to
tvtropes.com deus ex machina Latin
forgotten the machine is when a person
or thing is introduced to a story
suddenly providing a contrived solution
to an unsolvable problem chekhov's guns
is playwright Anton chekhov's principle
that a writer should make every element
of their story count if a gun is shown
in the First Act it has to be fired by
the last act ironically this rifle nor
the foreshadowed telescope are ever seen
again in this episode gratuitous
violence is pretty self-explanatory as
is action enhancer a ticking clock is a
story device used to ramp up tension
Rick then explains to Morty why this
isn't a likable premise for the episode
it's funny when Rick makes a few casual
popcorn your references here and there
but he doesn't want any of this season 3
Moonlighting [ __ ] this is a reference to
the late 80s TV series Moonlighting the
detective dramedy that put Bruce Willis
on the map the show was known for
breaking the fourth wall addressing the
audience the show's writers the network
and even the series itself at times when
these two dudes enter The Meta Lair
there are too many story device puns
floating everywhere you look it's no
wonder these glasses blind Mori the
second he steps inside writing jokes are
literally all over the place before
Morty takes them off we see the words
narrative threads escalation leap of
faith Cliffhanger and watershed moment
Flash before his eyes narrative threads
are the arcs and mini arcs that weave
together to form a full story as Rick
and Morty Traverse The Meta layer we see
pink strands of these narrative threads
hanging from the trees escalation is a
story device that increases the
anticipation and intensifies the story
over time represented here by the Steep
Mountain stairs before them the leap of
faith moment is just what it sounds like
the moment a character puts their trust
in their acquired skills or Allies and
takes a risky jump into danger later on
we see a clip shaped like a coat hanger
a literal Cliffhanger which is when a
character in a precarious dilemma has a
shocking Revelation at the end of an
episode lastly a watershed moment is
basically the point of no return in any
Story the exact moment that changes the
situation for good and is likely
depicted as these steep waterfalls we
also see a Kabuki theater mask floating
in the sky representing this form of
Japanese dance drama storytelling the
fifth principle of Kabuki performance
incorporates audience participation a
type of force wall break as they begin
their Journey Morty asks Rick if they
should follow a signed March trials
leading up a mountain and Rick responds
that have previously on went that way
he'd end up a hero this is one of the
many references to Joseph Campbell's
17-point Heroes Journey monomith the
majority of popular stories are
structured around the sixth part of a
hero's journey is the road of Trials aka
the point in a story where the hero
begins facing conflict after crossing
the threshold fittingly we see this just
as Rick and Morty cross the threshold
into the metal layer beginning their own
Road of trials for the episode while
walking Rick says our credibility is
being permanently eroded every second we
spin here is the equivalent to 10 Space
Jam cameos this is obviously a reference
to 2021's widely panned Space Jam a new
Legacy where Rick and Morty made a brief
appearance this joke further emphasizes
the episode's message that the overuse
of meta humor can cannibalize a story
show or movie in the background still
spell out the word Quest the search or
Pursuit made by every hero to obtain
something of value to them and a giant
word balloon is floating above plants
that turn into open books as they grow
Skyward these seem to be the stages of a
TV show from bad ideas that are cut to
show Bibles to script Pages the full
stories with multiple narrative threats
when Leon pops out from behind the weeds
you can see that they're labeled weeds a
reference to the term in the weeds used
by writers to describe the experience of
getting hung up on Minor Details and
losing the story's focus when they catch
up with previous Leon he prays to Jesus
Christ to stop Rick from shooting him
this is the exact move that fictional
Rick made in never Ricky Morty to trap
the story Lord in a Bible tale and it
turns turns out that both Paul Giamatti
and Chris Maloney are back baby gutters
and all although Rick and Morty tried to
get out of there as soon as Jesus shows
up Dory Lord stops them pointing out
that what Rick just did was a refusal of
the call another storytelling device and
the second stage from Campbell's
Monument this is the part of any story
where the hero refuses to engage in
their conflict before being forced to
deal with it Morty remembers that
storylord is the villain from the toy
train he bought for Rick at the end of
never Ricky Morty Thriller tells them
that since they trapped him in his own
private VeggieTales hell he's convinced
Jesus Christ to become his muscle and
helped him transcend fiction and enter
met a reality Morty says introducing
Jesus to beat us up have you seen South
Park a reference to the season one
episode Damien in which Jesus fights
Satan also in the 2024 PC game South
Park the Stick of Truth you can actually
summon Jesus to Aid in battle like
storylord is doing here and it turns out
that Jesus is a pretty deadly fighter
who knew he slams Rick down over his
knee a la Bain from 1993's comic Batman
Nightfall
[Applause]
despite Rick's attempt to get Morty out
of there by passing him the remote Dory
Lord steals it claiming that he wants
motivation and will stop at nothing to
get it motivation is a term used to
define what drives the character's
action within a story and in a story
Lord's case that driving Force's
motivation itself when Jesus seems
surprised that his buddy bailed on him
through a hole in the fourth wall Rick
wonders if this is enough to make Christ
an unlikely Ally kind of makes you want
to be our unlikely Ally huh another
storytelling device where a character
swoops in out of left field to save the
day before Jesus can kill Rick and Morty
Leon sucks him into his own previously
on spiral becoming the actual unlikely
Ally in this episode Jesus receives a
full Dan Harmon story Circle within this
spiral as he deals with the conflict of
being a demigod and wanting to be with
Mary for those of you that don't know
Rick and Morty Creator Dan Harmon made
his own simplified version of Joseph
Campbell's Heroes journey to encourage
screenwriting success while working on
community here Jesus starts in a zone of
comfort as a prophet then wants to be
with Mary his F1 turning point is his
crucifixion and is entering a new
situation is the Resurrection on Jesus's
Road of Trials he visits Napoleon
Bonaparte who has Jacques Louise David's
famous 1805 painting Napoleon crossing
the Alps hung above his mantelpiece also
people step stool next to his chair
that's there because he's a little guy
Jesus eventually adapts to his new
situation as a billionaire I'll ask
Steve Jobs with the means to resurrect
Mary when he gets what he wants at the
cost of Mary's well-being he seeks the
witch to turn him into a normal man
Jesus getting struck by lightning to
stop his mortality invokes the imager of
a Highlander quickening and allows him
to return to the Act 1 status quo of
being Immortal finally able to grow old
Jesus Embraces mortality with a nurse
named Mary bringing his story arc whole
circle if you like Rick and Morty
staying hydrated and feeling alert and
energized have I got news for you now
you can pick up the G fuel unstable
portal fluid inspired by Rick and Morty
this sweet juicy and sour Strawberry
Limeade blend will hit the spot whether
you're tuckered out from a fun day Jerry
Berry or just you know thirsty like a
person the tub is a bunch of fan
favorite characters like Mr meeseeks and
Mr poopybutthole and other fun Rick and
Morty references inside the tub you've
got antioxidants Focus aminos vitamins
and other good stuff to get you jump
started on your day G fuel also has all
kinds of fun energy and hydration
formulas including ones branded around
other content you love click the link in
the description and use code new
rockstars to get 30 off your order
thanks to G fuel for sponsoring this
video meanwhile storylord inspects the
back of a story train toy box which has
the website storydashtrain.com from
never Rick and Morty written on the back
a call back to the anticlimactic link
that redirected to adultswim.com The
Story train was manufactured at Citadel
toys LLC 839 gleap floor Boulevard on
airstaz9 airstaz is an adjective used to
describe a product made or used as an
inferior substitute so this toy is
basically like a shittier version of
something made by Lionel trains Dory
Lord walks in on his rider heating up
cold hot dog with a lighter and the
episode takes its most meta dive yet
seemingly revealing the behind the
scenes story of the writing process
behind season 4's never ricking Morty on
the Whiteboard you can see a story
Circle for rickleberry Tales
Brickleberry Tales is obviously a play
on the Canterbury Tales Jeffrey
Chaucer's collection of stories tied
together as Tales shared by characters
on a pilgrimage and the inspiration for
never ricking Morty also on the
Whiteboard are the names goombie and
tickets Please two characters from never
ricking Morty we also see Batman poker a
reference to the episode almost got him
from Batman the Animated Series where
all of the villains in Bruce's Rogues
Gallery sit around a table and will call
their Adventures fighting him this was
apparently another inspiration for the
scene in never ricking Morty where the
train passengers tell each other tall
tales about their encounters with Rick
throughout the years there's also a
stack of toy trains in the corner and a
box of Wiggle lips bobble heads below
the Whiteboard Rick and Morty characters
are known for their distinct Wiggly lips
this must be a bunch of air status Funko
pops on another whiteboard a graph
explaining distribution structure the
process of getting a product to a
consumer is charted which is a comment
on how this Series has become a vehicle
for selling work Rick takes the captured
Leon to the headquarters of the
self-referential six a team of five
superheroes whose Powers correlate with
yet another slew of Storytelling devices
we've got Miss Lead who misdirects her
opponents flashback who can travel to
past memories on Ingenuity air who jacks
up the continuity of the scene protago
Nick who has the power to make anyone a
protagonists and Mr twiss who uses smash
cut grenades to suddenly transport his
opponents to another scene the sixth
member of the team is another twist
because the sixth member of the team can
be anyone talking to Mr twist when he
decides to make his reveal the twist is
there's no sixth member and he tells
that to everybody the duo escapes and
Rick takes them both to the holding cell
of Brett Khan a vigilante with the power
to make things always have been other
things so when Morty suggests he changes
name to retcon to fit the actual name of
the story device Brett makes it so that
his name was never Brett to begin with
it is and always has been
his design clearly takes inspiration
from the omnipotent Dr Manhattan of
Watchmen brick suggests that retcon make
it so that they were never in the metal
layer at all and Promises to use the
butter passing robot from season one
Something Wicked This Way Comes to free
him remotely once they're home what is
my purpose to wait until I tell you to
pull the lever
what is my purpose you pass you pass on
her
oh my God but although although retcon
configured his terms Rick frees him to
help him fight against the SRS reko's
full Scarlet Witch versus the Illuminati
on their asses proving how op reality
warping powers can be although they
escape they've been past the fourth wall
for so long that Rick and Morty start to
fade from reality luckily they're
rescued out of the cold by Joseph
Campbell himself voiced by his modern
day equivalent Dan Harmon he arrives
like a wise old man with soup from the
depths of the storm to save them he
tells them that he almost didn't make
the soup because his last name is
Campbell then I thought stay in the
moment Joe follow your bliss follow your
bliss was the philosophy attributed to
Campbell after the broadcast of his PBS
documentary The Power of men his concept
of monomyth or one myth refers to the
theory that sees all Mythic narratives
as variations of a single great story
The Gag with Campbell challenging Rick
and Morty to name a story without an old
suit man is a playful criticism that
Campbell's Monument doesn't actually
work for all stories ever told inside
Campbell's home there are a bunch more
writerly Easter eggs to find like framed
images of the All-Seeing ice symbol a
burning book and H.G wells's Invisible
Man as well as the oroboros hanging over
the door frame his Game of Thrones Hall
of faces esque wall decor is a reference
to Campbell's book the hero with a
thousand faces and later on in the
episode we also see a book titled A
Melody of water and Ember that's clearly
a play on George R.R Martin's A Song of
Ice and Fire check out that bottle of
whiskey the label reads writer's courage
aged in the belly of a whale which is a
reference to Stage 5 of the hero's
journey the belly of the whale is the
part of a story where a hero Must Die
metaphorically or literally to later be
reborn actually later on in the episode
we see that his entire house is the
belly of the whale it's shaped like an
actual whale the interior has a giant
rib cage and sternum lining the ceiling
after nearly dying Rick and Morty have a
toned for their transgressions and are
ready for growth and rebirth after
finding a mine rich with narrative ore
Rick spends years working on a new
device to take them home during which
the highly esteemed Joseph Campbell
calls him and his grandson Back to the
Future rip-offs to be fair they 100 are
their Channel 101 pre-show Genesis forms
Doc and Marty are airstars Doc Brown and
Marty McFly when it's time to leave
Campbell gives them the note that they
should do more classic season one
adventures and note that I'm sure the
real writers of the show get all of the
goddamn time I'm so sick of that no what
the [ __ ] does it even mean Rick and
Morty take one final leap of faith and
trust previously on to help them get
home this time instead of trying to kill
Rick Leon actually sends them flying
back for the opening logo at the story
train manufacturing facility Dory Lord
has his rider hooked up to a giant
machine stacked with a butt ton of story
trains when he spins it the machine will
suck all of the motivation out of
everyone in the universe completing his
evil Quest and before you ask me if
yankmaster.com is a real website I'm
going to tell you right now that I would
get fired immediately if I typed in that
URL on a work computer so I did not
check it out
I'll do it myself
Rick rips off his shirt to fight
revealing his abs and causing story Lord
to exclaim gutters and a call back to
his stance on that term from never
ricking Morty I'm gutters that's what
people call them gross people I don't
want to have to picture I'm so watery in
such volumes that hey hey stay back you
tell a story Lord that he doesn't like
it before kicking his ass
I don't like that phrase I don't take
notes story Lord's increased motivation
gives him the upper hand on rip and he
taunts him by asking him to call him the
new Mr Nimbus a reference to the Neymar
parody from season 5's Mort dinner Rick
Andre when story Lord loses his powers
Rick is able to defeat him by literally
punching down a term that means to abuse
or insult someone objectively lesser in
some way even though he promises to be
less inside baseball Rick hands the
writer one of the airstow's Rick dolls
with the royal blue hair to smother him
with you have to use this brand new
limited edition Rick plush available
only on Rick Dash plush.biz supplies are
limited act now you did and by the way
if you actually go to Rick blush.biz
there's a fun web page this time the
site says that they now make the dolls
50 heavier you know to make it easier to
smother your enemies with Joseph
Campbell convinces the writer to stop
being a writer and Rick Burns The Story
train machine to the ground but despite
one of the most prolific screenwriting
philosophers of all time telling him to
quit the writer takes the advice as a
note to Going Back to Basics off to the
side you can see Campbell losing his
[ __ ] in their real medicines this is
Joseph Campbell reacting to this very
episode which has a writer insert
interacting with a story he wrote AKA
this dude grappling with a storyboard
the post-credits scene features tag man
another story device hero absolutely
destroying a bunch of people an episode
tag is a one to five minute mini act at
the end of a show after the dramatic
climax of the episode but before or even
during the end credits used to show the
effects or aftermath of the episode Rick
and Morty usually gives us a
post-credits scene but tag man is also
supposed to represent the Trope of wacky
characters that that show up throughout
the show in the tags like Mr Poopy
butthole what a cliffhanger oh boy oh my
that's a real crazy ending huh this is
definitely the most meta episode the
show has ever done so I don't know what
you guys think in the comments follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow me rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]